the surgeon will perform
abdominal aortic aneurysm repair to
prevent rupture of a
bulging area of the aorta the largest artery in the b
dy is the aorta which is at
ached to the heart and receives blood
directly from the left
entricle or pumping chamb
r  main the aorta is divided
into four parts ascending
aorta aortic arch thoracic aorta and abdominal aorta the
abdominal aorta is the last and
largest section of the aorta supplies
blood to the lower regions of the
body including the organs of the
abdomen and pelvis the aorta  abdominal
wall ends around the level of the navel where it divides into two iliac arteries that carry blood to the legs the aorta has a thick wall to be able to
withstand the high pressure of blood
that is pumped from the heart
over time the wall of the
aorta can become weakened by
slowly swelling outward like a
balloon when affected  n occurs in the
abdominal region it is called an abdominal
aortic aneurysm
the surgeon will perform an
open abdominal aortic aneurysm repair
when the diameter of the aorta
exceeds 2 inches 5 centimeters or
if symptoms such as severe
abdominal pain or an abnormally
prominent pulse occur  before the
open procedure through
an IV you will be started on
antibiotic fluids and
anesthesia a
serious traditional open surgical repair
with general anesthesia which means
you will be asleep during the
procedure a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and into  trachea
to help you breathe during the
operation when you are asleep
a catheter will be inserted into your bladder to
drain urine and monitor
kidney function
the surgeon will start by making an
incision from your breastbone to below your
navel
then locate the aneurysm and block
the aortic artery  above and
below the surgeon will then open the
aneurysm and in its place will be an
artificial graft with the same shape and
size as a healthy aorta
the surgeon will suture to the wall of the
aneurysm closed over the
newly placed graft the graft will
reinforce the walls of  the aorta
the surgeon will close the
abdominal incision with stitches the total duration
of this procedure is usually
4-6 hours
the surgeon will perform an
endovascular aneurysm repair a
newer, minimally
invasive procedure if you have
severe heart disease  or you are at
increased surgical risk due to age or
other medical conditions prior to the
endovascular procedure as
with the open procedure an
IV will start giving you
fluids and antibiotics you may receive
general anesthesia or a sedative and an
epidural or regional anesthesia for
numbing only  the
lower body
the surgeon  you will not start by making a
small incision in the groin
above the femoral artery then insert
a guidewire into the artery and
carefully push it into the
aneurysm a hollow catheter or tube will be passed over
the guidewire which will be pushed into the
aneurysm
using imaging  live x-ray
as a guide the surgeon will pass an
endovascular stent graft a compressed tube
of metal tissue through the catheter
into the aneurysm then open the
graft which will be held in
place with metal hooks and stents the
surgeon can insert components
additional grafts to extend the
graft into the vessels that supply
blood to the legs
once the graft has been placed
the blood will flow through the graft not
around the aneurysm sac which
will take the pressure off the aneurysm
lastly the surgeon will remove the
catheters  and close the
groin incisions The procedure will usually
take two to three hours.  After
the procedure, if you have a
breathing tube, it will be removed and you
will be taken to the
intensive care unit for recovery. You will receive
fluids and food through an IV.
You may also have a tube
inserted into your nose or stomach
to remove secretions.  until your
bowel returns to normal function
the usual hospital stay
for an open procedure is
5-10 days while for an
endovascular procedure it
is usually shorter at 2-3 days